what's up full podcast welcome to the
what's on full podcast with Felipe
Esparza and Rodrigo Torres Yemen and
over here we have Lisa hello just
chillin chillin do we work for other
stuff no I'm not I'm writing down the
tour dates alright what's up everybody
we're back we've been gone we've been
here since d-day ray yeah man the deen
dayal red del razor del razor so that
little bag the energy dog no more sugar
sugarless sugarless like a little stick
of sugarless gum dog I never knew - I
met him how fat sugar makeup you didn't
eat sugar candy candy
I can't imagine eating that much candy
how much candy did he eat he says in
candy and best it was with candy canes
candy yeah I'll Fabio the breads bro I
love for me it's beer like out like a
purse here they come hungry and I see
hamburgers and pizza but over there like
a red velvet cake with a line you know
cheesecake on top but let me think that
bro you love cake I do okay you owe me a
Christmas cake
what's up fool who's that crackling
noise a little bit real quick
Oh with me what is a Christmas cake you
ever heard of Christmas cake bundt cake
about King there you go
whoa Nikki answer don't answer it it's
not a Christmas cake fruitcake oh nice
cake I don't I don't have to fruitcake
or the right yeah that's nasty to say we
don't like a pillow thought of for Setar
me bro Nomad I still do restaurants try
to make it as try to make it like even
better like its capital tada but they
call it Mexican pudding one time I said
yes and
capirotada at the back take it back you
like rice rice pudding
[ __ ] yeah bro I never liked the growing
up faster than she hot I don't like he's
nasty my mom's always served it hot
and man you know back then with my
mother to teach about flossing so man
you know me man
that's tournaments tasted a mite between
my tongue between my teeth for years
little rice
no but capirotada everybody listening
and it's that is that during the
holidays Christmas holidays yeah this
with everything no you haven't know how
they're left over so like I guess of the
poor people food because it's like
leftover right faced back in 1800 when
it was nothing to do it like everybody
else with having cakes you know
Christmas cakes like bundt cakes and
fruit cakes so somebody got together and
put up what do you have bro I have
tortillas would you got it was like the
old ass bread leftover bullies and [ __ ]
like that won't put all that I'm gonna
shave you sir oh yes I will put Oh
leftover bread tortillas she will put
nuts as Oh a hoe plum dog I don't get
that a whole plum like cut up no the
boning yeah that's the buona be gone but
to be raised in a nuts bro like walnuts
and nuts n but it's like oatmeal
consistency right yeah man and then like
there was sweetness brown sugar yeah you
know you don't see you don't see you but
I never had a good couple of Dada in my
life but only one time I thought it was
good because I him I grew up I am burned
it a little bit so that she was gonna
burn so man that's what I thought I like
in apple pie with cheese bro because the
cheese in a couple thought I was melted
yeah they put cheese we never got cheese
in
Motors rock how the cheesy no like oh
just like like that
oh the shredded cheese like it was
blocks over there chunks not much and
then within Monterey Jack that would
melt it ruined the whole I should never
melt it bro I stayed right there like a
record
yeah so screw that but never like that
[ __ ] mom put cake sprinkles on it like
he's gonna make it better by mere that
without the rehab and I'll begin the
kitchen and we do um get donations from
Ralph's they will give all the leftover
cakes old ass cakes dude sometimes we'll
have like a cinnamon bun cake that was
so old that we have to put a lot of
frosting to trick out everybody dog even
like warm it up a little bit to soften
it up right but put a lot of frosting on
there dude so we'll know how old and
chewy it is I think I will always lie
man we're gonna make man we're gonna
make us souffle bro so set a souffle you
know when I make um I don't know the
third cake that you put you up or
something I mean you can't light on fire
creme brulees like flan yeah yeah the
Helios a creme brulee did you always
have a big things given me growing up
ooh
it was like it wasn't super big dude but
just like a turkey and ham hell no I
should go Gabon special like six months
brother would do okay Maura but Charles
Dickens story normal what a Norman
Rockwell painting
goose goose I guess so wherever is Jesus
what's that like Christmas sorry man
Dickens sorry he goes up ho get the
goose the biggest goose you can find but
don't they say goose British he's over
there
there's you Goosen on that and I don't
think I don't know that the turkeys were
domesticated over there Turkey's like an
offshoot of they've even have documented
Turkey was likely in like
yield wilds so that that's a point we're
by the way you know swad very good smore
and I know that Amana really the
pelicans bro
oh I know that Pelican like they'll
serve like quail in some places you know
like wild we allow young hens nieces
yeah yeah I've never I've never made
them but I made them at people's house
sometimes I felt like eating Cornish hen
or this would just give me up beat Sean
was heavy a pigeon I've never danced
from they were I went with a bunch of
kids hunting for them bro they were all
gone a fool there's these people that
live over there by Drew Street and the
avenues that they eat Beach on dog
because they're from their little dog
and I think the street ones like that
guy in a trailer park really homeless
eating squirrels he would he would gut
the squirrels the beans yeah mad but my
favorite cake is a German chocolate cake
by the way Celine all Vitas a German um
German um chocolate cake it's dark
chocolate yeah and some yeah and the
regular chocolate came here in America
is a milk chocolate like though my
favorite cake is dumb
I always tell people is the yellow cable
Duncan Hines oh yeah I made that one's
for you
once I like those boxes are chalk
they're good the cakes they'll kick in a
box although the back one we sell made
up Cayetano in a hotel with a no good
oh yeah ha dude munchies dog
no but we had dealt those at Walmart
probably and she put him in the mic oh
by the way I was staying in um when I
won't end in Corpus Christi that one
time when Lisa we're doing Gators with
John Roman but it was um I was staying
away from the ocean rose in a city brew
like there was actually cars really you
know when you know you're resting April
reg I didn't I'd never been there before
I didn't believe that there was an ocean
nearby I was like if there's nowhere
this is like strip mall central we were
yeah we're staying at Bluffs where they
got little hearts apart high school yeah
cuz you oh you've always stayed by the
bay favorite yeah man a big run in bro
yeah man so another way for our
Thanksgiving it always been Turkey I'll
let you like I mentioned last year with
my aunt and my mom ruined there by
making tamales they boil that [ __ ] the
entire turkey the entire church just to
make the meat for the tamales and
Salvadorans have sandwiches I found that
out the wrong way fun fun the power like
a little bun de pavo
I didn't we were vegan at that time we
found out so we were really happy we
brought our own food with us I don't
know what's up with it like I was I
don't what a sandwich what you did you
save the tricky Mito after to make the
sandwiches yeah I mean I always thought
it was a leftover sort of idea but no
this is the main course for them well
they do it done there huh it was funny
when his brother walked in Albert walked
in offended damn we didn't have a hand
for Easter we didn't have he didn't
realize that this was like a traditional
thing he was like there's no Turkey
there's no ham what like he was all mad
about that dude that'll suck it but then
everybody turned to his brother's wife
it was like kind of embarrassed because
this is encourage our family's tradition
yeah man you know it's about family with
a dad it has no shame you know flossing
in the living room
that bomb the bubble sticky on that word
for it chomp-chomp no oh I was watching
choppy lies on the internet I was on a
plane flying watching just burrito bro
and I was dying
edible I did why'd you call that fool
that do you reminded you that for right
now that did I remember that for found
out I left for was bombed hey man I
don't like jokes
I don't like nicknames too often it
means hang our people you're a
conscience who are Salvadorian friends
later from El Salvador is that from
Salvadorans in America oh I don't know
that powers over there but I'm saying
will they find those turkeys over there
did you drop they got a bunch of bachata
together bro used to watch as a kid hell
yeah baby oh come on don't let him dog I
totally forgot about that photo you
brought it up that one time I mean I
used to watch the reruns as a kid that's
about it dude oh my god yeah man so
what's up fool should be enough to bear
everything shows coming up now right now
but I did a show last night
we're at in West Covina with all the
guys from the old school you know really
man guess no one got paid
who was there bro Shabana Alfred Oh
Johnny Rocky and this dude named babbles
before
offer oh we had the guy with the newest
clothes oh hey Roble knows how to do it
bro you show up for the road man you
don't have to talk about this show up
with new stuff if it starts that will
happen bro Gabriel bought you those
shoes I said about you bought my truck
okay it's like it's like you can't so
you gotta swap or front of them I mean
Alfred I showed with a crew cut you know
where my old sneakers I know man how
many I don't know man you can take the
food out to lunch you could take him out
to dinner they're never gonna be happy
oh dude man it's time to hand out
Kleenex it's Christmas again dog yeah
they're all out there bro waiting for
the next TV credit there's crazy stories
about the devil - hilarious
oh man - yeah oh man so oh then from
other room sharks shout out to Alex de
large bro
you said you that video who went to
every mall okay with the Apple store -
I'm sorry I spoiled my wife sentimental
feelings for her she's peace what she
should listen I forgot this is a
patriarchal you know in felt like we're
now at Drugstore Cowboy I'm at dinner
trying to make that deal and he goes you
should I Jack that homie for that out
for those pills it was over Jackie right
thing all his pilfer $50 in that chicken
man no but she did the right math and
she rested the deal and that bull was
kicked out of the house this yo Dee Dee
[Applause]
I love drugstore Cowboys yeah you like
them I love the way they dress that's
but but then you grow up and realize see
people are bums we're ahead of their
time on just sort of loser bro breaking
into drug stores just to xaniix its do
everything back in the day that's that
dude Max is not movie dog max now fool
you took a picture with us right bro -
that night we were talking about a
picture with me max max gleaming the
clear yeah the BC boyfriend yeah blow
his last name
when happen with Alex Gallardo
oh that fool he went to an Apple store
and um he got he subscribed all their
phones other tablets are their computers
to the worst of all podcast oh hell yeah
tape that dog are you serious that's how
you do it people that's how you get
invited to the anniversary show that's
how you get invited to the how you get
invited to the arm to the [ __ ] the
premiere that's how you get invited to
get a free vinyl that's right we know
the vinyls are here look at that
Felipe's boys that was so fool max
Pearlie yeah max per league yeah max
perfect for blue to a porter with him
one time in the rain and we're lonely
huh hell yeah we're by beer and I fooled
you we just he just surprised that too
big a fool recognize them and we got
around him and I put two good knife I'll
take the photo cuz I'm gonna strangle
him Felipe Esparza translated the album
is out people we got summer first
December first get your Bible and
digital release will be out December 1st
as well on iTunes Amazon Spotify all
those places only limited on vinyl
limited on final with 500 copies in
existence they're all stamped with the
foil stamp on the back they're all
numbered and there's a poster inside as
well and if you buy the vinyl you get a
download card and you can download the
digital as well only available online
only available only available online on
Felipe's WorldCom's last shop but it
won't be available until December 1st
let's look right on so once our food
what's that done yeah get all these
shows here dogs alright ladies and
gentlemen this week I think my eyesight
is getting better bro they're better
lighting I think because I wrote it on
yellow paper maybe oh let me see this
just um right I saw something else here
on some of your handwriting
let's try it over here Oh hold on wait a
minute I'll look at that old dried-up
blood left in there [ __ ] okay here we go
ladies and gentlemen my eyesight was
normal this week Ontario improv December
3rd sold out okay I do my glasses this
week ladies and gentlemen were in Odessa
Midland Texas
Odessa Midland at the what theater that
is the Wagner Noel the Wagner Noel
it'll be Rodrigo Torres Keith Manning
get off the field
mane and myself I forgot to give a get
up the feel for the rate of both of
scored 37 0 I think no no they scored
once 8 wow yeah wow the two-point
conversion and have another 1/2 of the
reader friends at the porting Marsh and
lynched in the next Mexican national
anthem he said they'll do Roberto and
then Trump start tweeting this morning
somebody told him who ratted him out I
don't know if well you know that was
watching hit was moments after it
happened he started tweeting what
happened and they tweeted again this
morning we see he was saying that he
should be suspended that the NFL should
consider suspending him for doing that
how disrespectful it was gotta tell
Donald Trump to get off the really yeah
dog but he had a good ass run a 25-yard
run dude first one dog but I shouldn't
be excited that they were routed 37 0
because the Chargers off by a lot - yeah
the Rams got pelted - dog around hard
doing good you know doing good egos yeah
dude only have one loss today when
usually once I get one everyone ok also
they won last night for competing would
be disappointing brother they make all
the way no make it alright no huh gotta
get to the Raiders what's awful I didn't
know that ageing of Zahle estilo 22
million dollars are you serious or not
today Dodgers one year cause oh yeah
that's what he's owed yeah Oh is he
gonna play don't get that guy Stanton
and this dumb this badass Japanese
player bro who could pitch and
it really so well he's not pitching he
thought the you know the age in Japan
really that he's that bad asking that
badass but do you want to gather they're
gonna be hitting and pitching bro I
don't know dog didn't seem to work this
is the last World Series run yeah man
all right at the gentleman next week
next week December 1st through the 3rd
sold out that's right
sold out on terror improv been sold out
for two months first time that happened
man
comedy magic club Hermosa California
December 7 sold out addison texas will
promote an elephant Texas Rodrigo and
Toby Hicks Nebraska's finest that's
right December 14 through 17 also man be
on the lookout I might be doing a comedy
store so that better pop pop up I don't
know where we won't promote it to the
night before so if you really want to
catch me I'll be doing a big show
with big comedians and a big audience at
the Comedy Store fool whatever get the
Comedy Store dawg I found my old setlist
from The Comedy Store bro I was going
through my garage could I have a garage
now and I found check this stuff I found
my set list from November 28 2009 damn
17 years ago look that's when I was
printing broke this Comedy Store
homeless because I saw this buff ass
homeless guy on a winter Comedy Store
and right yeah he was hungry I told him
don't ruin that body and and then dinner
about body piercing my sister's
overweight she got oh oh oh dance jokes
fool crappy car they stole my crappy car
you know I couldn't believe when they
stole my car man it's only free but I
stole your car really instead of being
sad flattered without Oh school broke
you know and they're like I had like um
I was going through the notebook dog
and man dude I got my budget here for
2000 the year 2000 bro look my rent was
three hundred and eighty bucks a month
so I live in a studio this small right
it was this small right the bedroom was
smaller than this actually it was this
size I just live in a room the size that
we're in right now a little kitchen for
380 month 380 bucks a month bro arm the
no one answer paint no water and didn't
have to pay for no gas and no
electricity so you know me but I left I
leave that leave the lights on so do you
and then my my phone bill was $78
landline landline and my car payment was
321 bucks bro let me tell you what my
copy or 221 bucks what happened before I
got strong-armed into a car deal with
Leo Leo financing of course he did
finance me and Leo the who do Leo the
Cuban capital credit like Leo was she
still around man Silver Lake he's a car
dealership is running on sunset
if you don't need a car man if you no
one wants to give you a car and you're
responsible man if you don't mind
someone knocking your door for that car
payment I always joke around with it
they ask me but how'd you sign up for
that car bro you practically paid trip
double what is worth the Montero yeah
the green Montero bro yeah it cuz it
went from five ninety five thousand nine
hundred ninety five dollars to seven
thousand $995 when I paid two g's and
half G's to win a financing and I
remember man my phase number 321 month
three $321 month and something will give
him war but one time I showed up late it
was gonna week late I put took the money
and that would say that he looked at me
sit at this you're slippin homie
fool I remember when I signed the deal
right his Cuban cousin had just got
released from prison you try it was
speeding down sunset on a red Corvette
with no t-shirt on bro buff as hell
dang no t-shirt on and you wearing just
jeans and cholo shoes bro he was born at
the park but no t-shirt on and he goes
ah man he said oh man and I thought he
was down right stat ah man
if he goes was that on my cousin man he
just got out who he just got out of the
Corvette oh yeah man he sells cars too
so so so bad as soon as that food came
in he was standing behind me then when I
stand yeah I'm out by the car
just keep this guy's a red Corvette away
from my house
excited the alright there who hooked you
up with that guy alright in there
really cuz you who else got a car from
that fool who I walked in there and
there was a girl working there and she
knew my comedy and I started talking to
him he knew my comedy then I said man I
want to get a car you know but I have
bad credit you know but I could give you
a lot down how much my check for my
first TV show came out when I did a
Showtime 96 96 so in 96 that didn't dime
that show money stamina little show on
Showtime
maybe 899 and then all those shows were
sold to CBS and that show was coming out
at 2:00 in the morning
luckily for sag-aftra Astra American
Federation of TV and radio on that place
they um they went after the against I'm
sure enough people complain and they I
got my money bro every one was sent to
jeez ah damn cut of the action got a cut
it's like we gotta know we got paid like
we just did the show again
so all those show that I was on they
send me a check and I use half of that
for a down payment the riff for weed
coach Gary glaze I got the first
channels of Flippa did you think you a
check from Kellogg from mom kind of
zeona from funniest funny he was not yet
then I got a check bro and I got it
funny is funny was the show before
Kellogg goes on lemon see it was hosting
it yeah man so that was my so that was
my car payment bro that was my budget
bro my budget was every month I had to
make one thousand and seventy nine
dollars so um I guess I have to be
hundred dollars right here so yeah man
so look at Matt I have my budget for the
next three weeks bro right here in two
thousand and I know this week I was
making $180 all right the next week I
was making 180 and Friday I was making a
hundred fifty bucks from one night so
bro that was my buck I'm out of my
budget dawg I don't think I ever made
ten thousand dollars in a year but bro
was three hundred eighty bucks on money
and rent and cheap dude that's a nice
pot for 380 dogs look at how my possible
que locura say right here
reflect on your life here we go home
after a night of partying partying and
reflect on your life every night you
laid down and you say man I haven't done
[ __ ] but then you hit your brother in a
bunk bed but you're the loser up there
for did that jus last night after or two
nights ago at the army base I want to
kill Vinny dog for when I have my Comedy
Store show come his door say from -
October 12 2000 star birth joke have a
tie ball joke Billy Blanks dog yeah man
because I remember I had a joke that
compared Starbucks coffee to am/pm
coffee cuz MPM [ __ ] like a dollar I
start but with three bucks and goes come
on man what would you spend a dollar for
coffee what would you spend three bucks
for covering Starbuck we need to go to
am/pm and order come back up for another
fifty and eat a doughnut with your
factor to the guy food Lakewood golf
tournament show and I remember that show
bro October 13 2000 it was me and
Gabriel glanced at the Rue de Varenne oh
we did a show for them bro and these guy
were golfing all day
you talk about being a sexist and macho
macho say Lisa machismo machismo and be
resolved smell chauvinist did with the
show bro those dudes are [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] Brett you know golf guys oh yeah
look at their shirts tucked over there
are really big bellies boys were all
that you know and some white guy and
some black dude bro the outfit doesn't
discriminate the type there was a cast
of Caddyshack bro
so I remember they show very well
because there was um a bunch of good
walking around bro and I felt weird for
them because I was weird it up because
there were all dudes and the only girl
that were walking around were all on our
girls the rock core don't have girls in
their bathing suits but yeah there are
the guys were like oh yeah bro shall I
lay down alright so then I got gonna do
comedy bro he goes man it was a man
still here a horny brother the other why
I excited like this girl's not gonna let
the bagra girl then I said that I'm out
it's a good show actually beautiful the
respective army was doing out here no
probs
the last show I didn't either bad ass
boy why is your girl man I said Wow okay
again the boy the 40 ounce of girl
shoulder yeah the golfcourse guys are
gross I used to be a beer cart girl the
legend of badge event I did it my first
year before I was old enough to wait
tables and serve alcohol there but for
some reason I was able to win no I hated
those guys I hated him shoot it then I
was hoping they'd never come over in my
car I didn't want to make money there I
didn't want to talk to any of those
gross
almost be yourself yeah your own beard
card yeah yeah I had it like I went hold
a hole and that there are three courses
so you compete with the other beer cart
girls it was just like it was tough
well then a beautiful girl with big blue
showing them off older ladies
yeah there was an older lady yeah piggy
she was very Peggy Hill like mm-hmm
Luanne but she had been doing it for
quite a quite a while every summer
doesn't we might be like king of the
hill when then she got that job at the
golf course yeah oh yeah there's some
older ladies
but they don't make much money nobody
likes oh man oh my god do you what we
have king of the hill on Amazon I think
it's on repeat it's time for king of the
hill and and now everybody's Raymond and
King of Queens gets played a lot at the
house but this is one episode man on
king of the hill that's pork bro I mean
for Peggy Hill I guess which one is the
one where um where our Hank goes goes to
the neighbor's house the old house and
she's surprising here was her name sure
hey sug you come over here heat up the
Nancy Nancy so this goes over there
brand and I'm Hank night he's never used
Carole he never used propane for that
for to warm up a jacuzzi
so I get some excited bro it's a very
sexual undertones special undertone
could either dream that he sees I'm
Nancy naked brother barbecuing but when
he's hooking up the propane and it turns
on the Jets he goes oh what he finally
gets that the propane connected and the
jet comes out at the same time the Jets
pringle he's all sweaty
so when peg asked him which team about
and she did is her bro but then when she
finds that he's dreaming about Nancy
she's hurt and then and then he wakes up
in a sweat in a cold sweat one night she
says what's wrong Hank did you dream
about some other ugly woman oh they're
all dream about john redcorn's lady with
another dream about me this guy that
Nancy
she thought Nancy was wearing a mask in
the Train
oh my favorite episode is what she's uh
the Spanish teacher substitute teacher
and that little guys getting on her
nerves and she spanked something in this
Bano pourable Wow a panther bro oh yeah
man so January people January I'm coming
to Boulder Colorado Portland Oregon
Chicago Illinois New York City
Coachella California Tucson Arizona
check out other dates links at Filippis
world.com slashed or december 1st
december 1st of vinyl also as you go
touring will be at these shows Boulder
Colorado
I think Boulder Colorado if you're out
there anybody on board Colorado if you
have a if you have a medicinal shop well
do me Rodrigo would love to do a meeting
green over there to promote our show and
we might get there a day early so if you
can't have a one in Denver we'll drive
up from Denver from Boulder you don't
mind driving right what's been a deal
over there man and we'll hang out man
and we'll bring a couple of by nose and
saddle over there for you guys and sign
them okay well just talking [ __ ] I'm
just worried about you taking vinyl on
the road to another place special box
special bucket by nose we can't we can't
open that one huh I don't want to open
that one cause it's numbered we'll get
one of the ones that's not you haven't
opened it up yet no the in the test
pressings just a test pressing normal
yeah there's no artwork in the test
pressings huh looks badass dude I like
it heavy vinyl too by the way it's the
big one a good quality yeah I'm
scratching my nose
look at my nose eat a booger or look at
the back bro it has a Tony Danza
Estonia's and on the front row the sub
t-shirt Birdman Rodrigo in the back and
then that's Raymond fiddler the native
guy from the cup of the guy for not
finish the bike club and then isaiah's
in the back boy the past passed away
last last year before the special was so
badass by going right
wow man so the album is how long it's
it's a full hour we broke it down in
four-four records two albums I guess
nice can I have to say something this
vinyl has the recording of the Sweet
Caroline bit on the vinyl album out on
the special it's no it isn't a special
but it's not on the digital oh okay so
it does appear here on the vinyl it does
not appear on the digital because of
rights and having you know we had to pay
to use that for you to do that job Neil
Diamond we had to pay the guy who pulled
a Oviatt as well but it was worth it to
keep it in the special it's a good joke
special thanks to Kelsey at Lim ICM our
magical Bilborough
Oscar Morales our teen comedy and my
brother Fernando aka buddy who took one
for the team
he's tight huh yeah the insides nice -
we should text Oscars you can bring the
nun numbers vinyl ever - huh yeah check
it out people you can see that what's up
fool bad bro how you been man good I was
a [ __ ] I'm looking to be here bro
why what'd you see yeah it happened for
I woke up in a morning
really I was my last I did 8th Army
shows 8th army bases and the last one I
did was it was one hour north of
Syracuse I was 20 minutes
from the Canadian border oh damn so
you're all over there by Niagara Falls
and yeah my man I'm close to that I was
by one of the lakes from the Lake Erie
was near me in New York I don't know
which one it was they didn't tell me but
I was there now for drum for drum by
Watertown New York upstate upstate and
brah we were leaving at 7:00 in the
morning okay and when I got up at 6:00 I
looked out my window and the cement was
still black you know the concrete or
asphalt but I but I could see that it
was snowing
I like the reflection of the of the of
the winner of the lights outside you
know sometimes you can see in caught it
I caught it right and it was snow coming
up snow coming up dude
so at 6:20 I looked outside again right
it was still black but a time I came out
at 7:00 it was white food the ground the
ground everything brought like West
Nyack New York all of us are powdery
soft snow and our driver picked us up
right I saw um finis Mitchell outside
chilling waiting and then I told a
driver man um are we gonna make him an
nothing you know for somebody who
doesn't live in snow bro so I said
everything so man this is nasty dog sit
him in the Army 30 years you know
driving everywhere bro shooting people I
trusted him again seen it all full of
you more bro humor
that fool man I never been and never I
never been anywhere where there was snow
and we were they only wasn't a road dog
like look behind although no one nobody
came in front of us then I kept thinking
about we uh either be safe it's better
if nobody's driving bad yeah there's
only one trip once one car track bro and
we're following her we couldn't see him
but only one car in front of us I know
that because I could see the tartlet
tire tracks
and then man but it was not snowing
anymore but it was all white and then
I'm Fidesz Mitchell say hey man now I'm
gonna be alright so he pulls over to the
side and there was like four 18 wheelers
who boots was tied to and then guess
what bro a snow plow passed by so thank
you Jesus
we follow that [ __ ] for talk for
as long as he can't drive and we follow
him to the end of the road dogs going at
35 50 45 miles an hour then we got to
the main highway and it was open man but
it don't snow on the side of it but
there was no snow enough on the dirt
they cleaned it out they cleaned it out
then it was like going fast bro oh fast
we swerved a little bit really anyone
man we were so fast my head oh man one
of those time when I was in the backseat
guiding the road was my eyes bro like oh
man so man we get to the Syracuse no
snow in Syracuse yet but over there was
snow hell how far was it from the
airport like 12 I'm now wearing 50
minutes there it is here we go probably
got the vinyl the opening is the
backdrop of the show so you can see it
right there
a little saw that poster dog there's no
poster in this one I don't think wait
there is a poster oh [ __ ] they come with
a poster yeah man it's nice CHP poster
come with a poster and come with a
digital team did you think Oh
check it out people at 33 but hard to
read anything crack of someone's head
those are the ones who are like left out
out siding on the Sun they get all
brittle man not supposed to break yeah
man so we're driving through the snow
fool it's driving through the snow I'm
like I have one little caramel edible
okay I'm glad they needed
well I'm paranoid the whole time when we
get there man we - that guy man thank
you very much for bringing us name off
my job was he in a hurry
he has to be in a hurry Oh bro we had to
get him to the airport on time but they
weren't it was just you know like a man
I think he left what an hour and a half
before when I wanna have dinner tonight
and that's the storm feels crazy for
crazy
I'll show you what huh whatever would it
felt like nope I would look at her get
there bro it was crazy
hold his helicopter right now even
before the snow got there it was 34 when
he got there then it started snowing and
the other comedian I was 16 Smith he
left the night before he got he lucked
out bro he would have been in all in the
mix yeah 5-hour Drive damn to Brooklyn
that's crazy
I don't know why you'd want to drive all
the way down there so I did eight shows
fool but man the one of the better shows
I did what I have fun in all the shows I
did but I'm Louie
Brooklyn bro oh my god Brooklyn I did
I'm Ford Hamilton it lets in Brooklyn on
Bay Ridge like little babe the Bay
Bridge bridge no it's a very sauna
Verrazano Bridge it this big bridge
narrows and man we're not talking to the
guy from the army how long has it been
here he was being here tonight
17 is 1812 1870
I think 1786 right yeah well that's a
little right after the Revolutionary War
that was like to protect them from the
British showing up again and taking over
Brooklyn
he said that there and I'm had the
president been here he goes what
happened president rub in here he goes
better than some being here one time you
before you were president he was gonna
buy this place I'm making him
condominiums
right at the water blue the prime spot
prime probably it's like what Manhattan
Beach I mean Manhattan Bridge area is
now like not that Manhattan like down
under the Manhattan Bridge they call it
Dumbo down under the Manhattan Bridge
overpass and it was like squatters and
stuff for a long time but then now its
primary list of you in my hotel New York
right there bro nice and quiet to chill
chill man oh we're and when we get to
Brooklyn man it's like right you know
Steve they're like man red brick houses
nice neighborhood be rich man that's
where Fred grew up right yeah the cheap
cheap hezbi right sheep said man thought
it was Bay Ridge all right
it's nearby then we're driving away I
saw Coney Island I saw the the
merry-go-round
it's nice neighborhood man I liked it
his we went to the guy's house to hang
out and do they own the apartment his
mom bought in 2004 four hundred thousand
damn back then you had an apartment bro
let a house there's no Lord not like a
whole floor and the whole apartments a
regular preneur it is just like any
other any other apartment where you
can't you cook in the whole house Mouse
[Laughter]
but now that you said it was worth like
707 that mean someone else owns the
building you live in the he sells it
you're done or what no you'd still own
that piece but you'd have a different
person managing it I'll pay a little fee
like you pay usually a management fee or
co-op fee or whatever so I went on top
of the roof and kicked it old eyes man
I'll get a photo man
i starved though there was no food but i
want to go either a Thai restaurant over
there it was good bomb bomb
they have roti damn and they had curry
oh yeah the bomb is hell roti and curry
is the best thing in the world how do
you sustain out there for eating another
body well because they give them the
snacks as the writer but the kitchens
they just don't have like the people
equipped to make a vegan meal so or like
anything off them off the whatever
they've got right we make sandwiches
they make what do they make for the
other word for Aberdeen Maryland that
please I don't know there was good food
there there was a guy man that was the
the chef there he he was another guy
that was in the army 25 years and
retired and open up a restaurant on the
base
damn man had the same personality at
that sheriff over there and Pueblo bro
the airport ah when we were there with
Marcela yeah the brother right there
yeah he just had to work on his red
burrito rap game but the food was bombed
yeah that guy he look just like him
brought him the food here like a
vegetarian chili
shoutout to forever Dean and that guy
man that chili was dude it was delicious
[ __ ] he made me a veggie burger too
so when I got to my room bro just poured
that chili over my burger microwaved it
and I still had a vegan cheese leftover
BAM good chef did a meet-and-greet after
I was done cooking ah yeah they were all
happy bro like against the those a woman
like she's an officer man she's an
officer by a sergeant or something she
was wearing her whole camouflage outfit
she wasn't man I drove fast for my job
to get here I didn't have time to change
she is she was so happy you want to see
the show wanna see the show
there were a lot of black people man who
I are my fans and showed up to my show
right there New York yeah and older
ladies too like older woman like older
women who watch NBC you know stay up and
watch television the older people they
they were at the show to a car
staff sergeant lieutenants worth the
show maybe one colonel I wanna show into
the show oh man but he still had a good
time
oh yeah I did mostly people at the show
where our families of the of the
soldiers and and workers who work on the
base they get paid well bro I bet if
you're a family member of the soldier
you can go into the base to my grandpa's
bin' and my step grandfather he died
from war injuries and she was still
always able to go to the base to the the
BX the commissary and to get groceries
and stuff and buy stuff there they were
good man yeah there's but something oh
man well financed Mitchell was gonna be
here right but he was on he's gonna do
Tony rocks game show but it was for
hanging out with that fool man
cool Sal he's cool as hell man I didn't
know that he played for the for the
University of Miami really he played
with um a lot of people aid with or
worse at are you seen a team what's
University of Miami Hurricanes yeah
they're up right now yeah really doing
well right they don't know what The Rock
two played over there no when the rock
was there finesse Mitchell warrants that
were there okay so he's a class-a
athlete then oh yeah is he vegetarian
vegan - no hell no some barbecue the
first they were there they had our wings
for the amount of time that going you
will love them you know man
like you ever had like barbecue wings
and they're runny oh yeah no matter how
they do it brother no no you pick it up
and in the old but they were opening up
and they were hot and I just picked one
of each is the only look like and man it
was good it was crispy with a lot of
barbecue and then eye candy dog I don't
want to sound like a snob one of those
fat fools that knows all about food we
do you know how they do you do it with
the when
done right and you bake them that's the
best way but then you put the sauce on
it you let them sit and then you put
them in the oven for a little bit more
yeah oh that's that's the way they don't
get all runny at all they can get runny
too if somebody puts too much butter
exam because if not it gets a little
candied and stick to it's a little
crunchy would it do a fresh your mom's
dad that's how he makes them come I will
make bloody barbecue at your best oh my
how they make barbecue chicken blood is
always afraid of bloody chicken I don't
even understand how he gets that way
when they deep-fry it dude scares me
I've eaten a piece of barbecue chicken
that was cold in the middle dog cooking
at too high a temperature so the outside
will start to get burnt and I think it's
done yeah instead of realizing it's got
to cook slowly so the inside gets done I
don't want to get busted complaining
though we a that we ate it our one
waffle house bro and somewhere in
Alabama so far yeah Fort Rucker what I
have nothing no I ordered a hash browns
with all the vegetables all right they
didn't know oatmeal there no no meal Oh
No Oh be on the menu or grits no good
yeah but grits have butter always have
butter but a lot of different type of
people show a lot Dino were in there
eating raw salsa and finesse I saw his
story he made he had those grits with
cheese but they had a lot of extra
butter and I was swimming in Greece it
was like half an inch agrees on top
that's the only way you can eat them
those no they do you they still give you
those butter for the wall to peel yeah
the whole school one yeah then you put a
little bit of brown sugar no you don't
like that I never used to like oh man oh
you're taking my sweet grits yeah no
right
no but that's basically what cream
elitism yeah I mean that's corn grits
made from corn but
creamer we yeah you've always liked it
yeah I made it horrible though I'm gonna
put no sugar well I never even salty
what's up will you have fun at traffic
Kalia
sorry Kalia bro have forgot about that
it was tight dude oh my god man my mom
was there my brother with her party Lisa
Isaac sleeping well the Regal has lady
beanie and [ __ ] missing in action at the
end was he going to pick up where did he
go but he went to go see the tigress
from the front and then out he didn't
get to go with us to the see this cute I
like the way that how they walk around
the stage where they were at their
actual party dude nobody got on that
stage there they were tight that
drummers bad dog you know the the
baddest person is in that bass player
huh smokes DG bossy lord I know a lot of
people talk about like leaper and Jocko
and all those guys or heavy metal dudes
Steve errors that dudes a badass look
dear the North day man we were at the
talent show and we're going backwards on
what happened but that was by the best
of the best right there man it was sold
out I had a lot of tacos yeah you know I
ate a few just backstage there in that
back area they cuz we went back behind
there you didn't stay with us that for
that long right back there no we just
went and then till we got yeah but he
cuz they gave us a bunch more tacos when
we came back and I got some post-holiday
from the other guy but what I heard was
that for the before four o'clock they
were they were only giving out one like
a mini taco and you had to get back in
line to get more and it wasn't that was
the free stuff like it was samples
I call it samples on the nose so people
were upset by that because they had to
stand in line first I knew there was
gonna be a catch of course we won taco
sample taco not even like a full size
taco and then
do you if you wanted more you had to go
back to the back of the line to get them
back on the other one and then at four
they started selling the full-size tacos
I guess everybody good
oh yeah a lot of good varieties then you
hooked up the pictures with the TV the
North a hell yeah son
hell yeah hold here yeah they're good
huh yeah well let the guys still look to
see who know the kid bro do you know
about you believe it bro I'll show you a
picture I'll bring it next time
it's like from 12 years ago cuz I snuck
him backstage and took a picture with
him right there was a line and I just
got in there real quick and then they
assured me and there it's a Polaroid
I'll bring you the Russia winter like a
[ __ ] Kramer at the but you know
what's crazy a dude no that's one
backseat I mean I think I could I could
snuck in a tribal Kalia but I can't um
you know there's no way nobody could
sneak into their backstage camp yeah
that was like this unless you swam there
big-ass hand grabbed you by the throat
it's over I flew the old Mexican
luchador yeah that fool was there
messing around how did mom we'll get up
to the stands remember how we had to
finish that - we had to finagle and get
the Jorge to come help us get back on
the side what no you know what happened
after about 30 minutes of the set that
staff grope pro guy left that's what
happened because Vinnie was able to get
back because I left because my back was
hurting so I went backstage and MoMA
wasn't there and then the next thing I
saw this video little staff Pro guy I
left that guy your buddy that night -
huh he was telling everybody how how we
came up together me and Apple I was like
fool I made like seven times dog who
Momo he said you came up with them yeah
oh my god was it telling Rizzo and
rookie very weird ah yeah did you feel
you were to introduce me bro
how would it be it was intense
now a lot of people huh it was intense I
was never I was never said now it's not
to mess up what I had to say to you
through one joke one little joke what
you say
the gene Simmons or not gene Simmons but
the daily trade whatever they laughter
yeah but it was dude was it really more
than 16,000 people there I don't know
the cap was supposed to be 15 total
it was due when they were that's total
for all state the whole park was 15,000
as what was on the list on the breakdown
but because the right there be that
Chicago Batman set cause a like right
then is when everybody was all the way
to the back of the merch was and then
that sure was crazy
I think Chicano Batman had the biggest
draw of the headliners yeah you know
because even because Kelly you choose
people are starting to get excited
people were getting up there yeah then I
Batman well she was on earlier but then
when t guys came on some of the younger
people chose to leave at that point and
the crowd thinned out toward the back it
wasn't like when Chicano Batman was
there it was fully all the way to the
edge but loss to base I think people
took that as the opportunity to get beat
the traffic and stuff the last song
people were leaving yeah I think even
try to have them because they did a
75-minute set those pads when they went
up there though man solid old days these
little they big good together huh
they're bad dog I've seen him proud like
seven times he always done the same yeah
real good and they were the first duty
and they're all digital - no mic stands
dude yeah they had battery pack battery
packs on and stuff no amps no no wires
connecting them the drummer goes up
there first hangs up his little coat and
then he starts a beat and then those
fools just pop up playing yeah but they
have it all fine-tuned oh it's perfect
dude I noticed that just I mean not
trying to sound like a snob but you
listen the bass in the beginning this is
a little louder than that brought it
back down they saw that it was loud it
was perfect though like do you like they
really know how to you know rock those
big saves cuz I remember seeing like
phanzig started getting big and went to
big videos and they kind of don't really
have it dialed in and then you see
somebody that does those big venues all
the time to just like yeah it sounds
super important though and I'm sure
their crew that the crews goes from back
in the day all that [ __ ] do you do all
in a bag huh
yeah those fools ain't planned all those
soup
professional dog that data fool they
hired us to iron her clothes bro dad it
was like meeting my big old politicians
dog
it was awesome little Jews all right
dude enormous dude that's [ __ ]
nervous for the next day they do another
show man like nothing happened
they did a big show laughs let it cool
that God pool and then they're headed to
what Columbia yeah I told him that man
I'll tell you hold him up enough to get
it but we should do a big show bro
because it was time it was t get it they
wanna like reach out to the younger
audience so they knew who I was broke
and also I was shocked cuz that fools
kids keep the show from Sona throne is
the bass players kids over in San Jose
and then did your brother kill me dawg
it was in the back Porto sleep not Laura
[Laughter]
Steve Steve yeah your mom was all proud
your mom said puto scene I know what you
like in the eighties in their trailer
like in the 70s and a dude they were
doing movies that's where your mom cuz
your dance my Eddie right but your mom's
seen a lot yeah that's like because I'm
happy right oh hell yeah cuz I remember
like in in LA and the Greater Los
Angeles area it was really like all
these states now that you hear from
classic rock Vegas all that stuff that's
a newer like in like the early 2000s
because there was only really Sinaloa
that you know the horn of course you
know the music cuz you know the whole
culture and all that still wanna never
imagine Tijuana even in Mexico there we
started a low-class huh
yeah man do though now well it's always
that state that everybody would go to
The Fixer things to get ready to come to
the US but I mean most people came
because of a hookup or a family here do
you wanna basically the hub huh yeah
dude
that and look what is you know what is
man too little border cities man so I
was telling that throat and I get man I
was telling him that powered Regas and
now we did a big show where he did 20
minutes in nineteen twenty minutes right
before the bands went up he goes at them
and I told my low and on and then Tierra
and war
good we could do something like that it
were part of 30 I do 30 and then maybe
war or look at this los Tigres man we're
gonna then by that time you know because
I think this better man to do the comedy
first he can be put in no comedy after
it doesn't work in between which always
being like that oh yeah it so it's tough
I mean that's sort of I was really
stressed about that show and I wasn't
even performing and it wasn't that long
but the stressful part I'm stressed too
but hiding behind a big tough stressful
part is where it's waiting trying to
figure out like what kind of jokes would
work in a little five minute because
like you know let's say half those
people didn't know who you were and then
there were some who are fans and then
some people who had heard of you so you
do it you're mixing it up with your
jokes and stuff but it's like how do you
choose jokes to do in front of an
audience like that who's just waiting
for the next bang yeah that's even if
they like you like they're waiting for
the music to continue that flow into who
you are and who what your comedies about
is if it's a bad joke and that uh and
then the thing up until those days it
was running late it was running late
they cut the time a couple times that
you know that I heard more about the the
cheerleaders who were part of the scam
and jam jam and jam that the next act
was supposed to come up so they were
cutting their set but they hadn't told
them all they're kicking them on it was
like a lot of miscommunication like they
were doing their own thing and the
artists were doing their own thing and
they got in that shouting match and that
a few mad yeah because some of the stage
people were mad because they weren't
listening
they were DJing and performing right and
they were oh they're just doing set
changes in the middle of their [ __ ]
because they had to get the next set but
that's but that's the stage managers
issue yeah and that and it was bad bad
stage managing because he forgot that
these people are an artist they do have
fans here too and he didn't really do it
respectfully to get them off stage then
they didn't tell them ahead of time
which really said you can't pull
somebody off halfway through you gotta
tell them ahead of time I mean you got
to know that you're performing hopefully
they did know that they're performing in
front of a set change
that's a whole different thing but I
think they had a lot of stuff planned
not realizing that there's a set change
also going on I think they just I think
maybe that's Bestival thought it was
just supposed to be DJ stuff right you
know I think even as a performer you
gotta kind of improvise - yeah you saw
Brinson wood yeah dude you went over
there yeah well that was it right before
it was right before I knew I'd never
make it we only watched four song just
because I don't want to be late all that
and just it took a while to track the
president he was real good
the drummer looked my way he was a big a
big zoot-suiter yeah man he took it off
and was like dude he was really good
solid solid I did well with the audience
what was the audience like over by him
was it older older but also mixing a
little younger ones that probably like
heard his music growing up and stuff
like that
hey buddy Delfonics know I could make it
there because that was the beginning of
your self all right yeah they were
starting right after Bretton wood I
think I've got another guy that we're
feeling well with a power drink is
Philippe inspires a show you would bring
him up first
get away calm what's the budget yeah man
I think I'm a lot of a lot of some
people complain you know they didn't
understand my jokes this fella but but
thinking about it they're all fat chicks
dog do you see how somebody gonna you
know two people two fat chicks mad about
you doing a fat person joke really no
you know what it's like well these
people are so like that word comedy is
right now right these people don't know
comedy or they walk into a comedy show
for the first time and they hear fat
they hear woman and they put it together
all these guys and I said he's not miss
something miss talking this misogynist
fat women but it's not that joke that
joke that he did was the life raft joke
which is an old joke and he pulled that
joke out that joke is really saying like
women should wear their own size
don't try to fit into these smaller no
Fame just send red fat low though you
want to find out just just go on
instagram and search Felipe Esparza
and find yourself don't even know name
[Laughter]
anybody want something tailored to them
but you know what about this younger
generation
take it away not to take not to say that
they were complaining about the show you
know they had their complaints but
everybody had a complaint about
everything I heard people complaining
about the tacos when I was walking cuz I
got that 9:00 in the morning everybody
was little play about transportation
yeah I couldn't park there and then also
complain that it was hot really cattle
for now I don't get hog I don't get it I
don't get it oh they complain about the
everybody trust me dude is that but
nobody complain about paying $100
[Laughter]
missing everyone I read our article
about it and they mention my name but
they all say there was a success
yeah dude it was a bitchin show dude if
you went there's no way right they got
this because even though you had school
buses to transfer people away from there
it worked because all actually creates
problems it works you don't want to
Lincoln at one time you can have people
leaving at the same time but there are a
lot of people brought with were stupid
and drunk who are not waiting for the
bus [ __ ] walking in a freeway we saw
them on the freeway climbing up the hill
right near that where the trucks are
coming on to the we left right after you
guys didn't I seen all that stupid [ __ ]
man those guys for that bad the comments
can party bro dude I think there's
comments there was a lot of people that
wanted a party but could their party got
cut short cuz a little backstage area
had to get switched out yeah and then
gurus what so easily with a little
backpack show a little backpack was he
giving out samples
hey I yeah but my complaint I think if I
had really paid money to get in that
festival my complaint would have been
this Esparza the stages were so far
apart yeah hook forever to get back like
if you wanted to go hit one stage and
then see the next act on the next stage
like it was a long time and then if we
were to cut through the back of those
taco spots that's another 15 minutes
taking photos and take it with Felipe
like we couldn't go 10 feet
without getting stopped for photos 45
minutes yeah my never would have made it
back I think this appears disappear oh
my god his pal from school Johnny rookie
the Pacoima he must have just ran into
him out there huh and decided I really
thought you know as strange as it may
sound I really thought that you Johnny
rocky much of us were left together now
he decided to follow Johnny rocket to
the other place so the whole time he was
not was Johnny Rock we were not I don't
need them anyway they left together
Isaac and I together yeah on his own
yeah so what happened was we went to the
food court area I said I'm going to the
merch stand here to try and settle up
right to get them to start packing
everything up and then we'll pick up the
boxes later but you had to get them in
like an hour notice when you wanted to
pack up so I went to talk to the merch
guys Isaac said can I get some fries I
said okay I said go check over there and
see who has fries he came back said that
place has fries so I gave him some money
it's literally like I could have thrown
a baseball over there and hit it like it
wasn't that far and right after I was
done speaking with the people at the
merch booth I turn around
Isaac's nowhere to be found he's not at
that frie Stan he's nowhere he has a
blue Dodger jacket on nobody else did no
blue anywhere he was gone and I'm sorry
bending around like a TV movie like I
lost my son just now you know I'm like
spinning around I can't see any trace no
people around I mean no kids around and
then I go to the fry place did you see a
kid with a Dodger jacket like a little
white kid you know blond hair I went
over to the fries I mean to the security
it wasn't even security first there's a
medic tent I said where's security is
there a security tent near here he's
like well there's a guy out there the
red shirt they could help you and I said
all right so I went out there I
described what Isaac looked like and and
I said he was just here and they're like
huh Oh like they didn't have any I don't
know like sort of what am I going
do they had no plan I was ready to go
over to that little small stage that was
right near the merge area it's like a
fourth stage and asked them to like make
an announcement or something but
security was oh but I was freaking out
like this and I called you while I was
calling Isaac's phone I called my
Felipe's phone no answer I called Dana
no answer and I was like [ __ ] nobody has
their phone on Oh called Rodrigo baby
he'll be back they're floating around
and then you said he was there how do
you get there though then he must have
seen Johnny when we were standing in the
courtyard area so he lost you then he
lost me but I was standing I was right
there looking for him that you you you
have to be a parent to understand that
beer man
because my remember last time my son I
lost him Adam Nordstrom could eat my son
he used to like to run you know when
they have suits hanging around a circle
the clothing I wrap a little rack he
lets the high middle middle keeps going
to middle and high and then pop out
right out of the clothes so this time
couldn't find him the food fell asleep
in there bro my brother's looking for
that boy everywhere man we got our
showers I was a beat his ass but now my
purse my mama do baby she can't find you
frustrated buying your killing take up
that aggression somehow the way I might
article Lord but your brother got killed
huh yeah probably came back to life rest
in peace what's up fool man it's already
the years always ending crazy huh yeah
man I didn't do my bread like I told
myself gonna read a bunch of books every
night three you read three I read what
both fresh stole a booth they came out
paperback
Chronicle a new one about five minutes
to kill
I read five minutes to kill and I read
the one right here for I'm dying up here
okay and then I read
I read I'm dying up here right after and
after another book - yeah yeah are you
reading hammer the gods I saw that in
the bathroom yeah started that one went
up to that mean duffer
I started hammer of the gods yeah I'm
gonna chapter 201 I started I started to
and I both oh my the one you're reading
tell us what about that let's go I
little no that's the creature from
Jekyll Island that's a hard book to get
through because that's a factual book
that's not like fiction or anything
that's not about that's based on the
Federal Reserve and how that was created
after that meeting with JP who had that
meeting was JP Morgan Hall Warburg a
rockefeller
you know Carnegie was not there but they
were all they were all business men
owners all those deal major industries
like railroads steel banking as well and
so they were basically coming up with
the central bank idea and it was in 1914
Rothschild and they went off on this
meeting to Tekel Island it was a private
meeting they actually I mean it was so
furtive it was so secretive that they
connected their train they were acting
like they were going on a hunting trip
this is down in Georgia it's an island
off of Georgia they were going on a
hunting trip so they all dressed like
they're going on a hunting trip and then
they get in this train car and the car
is connected to this train that departs
but then that cable is disconnected and
they are rerouted to this other Depot by
themselves this one car and it just
backs right up and then they go
somewhere else but it was like a fake a
fake out that they were getting on this
train and the train went off somewhere
else but they had fake names no they
only had first names they had servants
at that island who didn't know who they
were like they weren't the regular
servants of anybody it was just
specifically hired just for that for
that trip and they all met in secret
about how they were going to set this
central bank up it's a
book but it's a lot it's like a textbook
it's and why did it do it because at
that time the US was making so right
after the Great Depression was before
the depression there was during World
War one but they were coming together
basically trying to figure out how they
could invest more money but still be
safe right and and they were still be
safe like protected if they lost the
money because banks at that time had no
way of investing beyond what they were
taking in because when they take in your
money as the savings you put your money
into a bank for savings it's immediately
gone and invested now and back then it
was - but these banks were getting way
too close to their edge of what they
were bringing in so they had no buffer
zone in case the investments failed and
people wanted to take their money out at
the same time yeah so it was like yeah
so it's like there was no FDIC at that
time so the FDIC started later but this
was a way to protect the bankers money
and it still works that way today
and the Federal Reserve sets like the
interest rates and sets everything for
how much money's gonna be worth
basically how much you know when he's
gonna be lended I thought Alan
Greenspan's did it he predicted the down
but the downfall is mentioned in this
book this book was written in the 80s
this is gonna happen that was yeah it
was just like it was talking about how
the Federal Reserve when these people
got together and made this plan it
worked it ended up working out exactly
that way when we bailed out those and
it's on our tab and that's how is
specified in these papers in these
documents that these guys put together
way back when is no secret there's no
secret it's like that's the way it's
gonna know they're gonna bail you out
it's like okay well what happens if the
banks all do default or they have
they're about to default it'll never
happen because we'll bail them out and
even if every American will go to the
bank and take it out they're still
protected huh still protected but the
whole
it's like the Federal Reserve isn't even
a part of the US government it's not it
never was part of the government but
that's why some people think there's
that loophole where they don't have to
pay tax they go after drug dealers in
small country because they took over a
bank that that part of the central bank
so is that one of the reasons for it to
not be attached to the government I
don't know I don't know what the
reasoning is but I don't think that I
think that if if it were part of the
government then we would have the
taxpayers the people would have control
over that you know what I mean because
it's not part of the government
officially I think that's always there
out one of the legislators can't have
the people control of it huh yeah
private it's basically a private I mean
it was but that's usually who pulls all
the strings anyways or the captains of
industry people that make like mad money
book is interesting but I haven't gotten
through it at all
how many pages probably you read it's a
tome it's like a thousand pages or
something with the other book do about
Scientology's all the big ass book going
clear I was fifteen hundred pages I was
good though I hate that like candy I
love Scientology obsessed with cold
crazy stories you read yeah I've heard
that one last year that's a good book
her book was crazy talking about Tom
Cruise and she got shunned because the
whole time she's at Tom Cruise's wedding
she's friends with JLo personal friends
through her husband because he was like
a dancer and backup singer and star with
Mark Anthony so they were friends and
then she invited her just to go let's go
to Italy I'm going to Tom Cruise's
wedding you want to come she's like sure
but the whole time the Scientology
people were trying to get Lea to get JLo
and Mark Anthony to be alone with
Scientology people like the the heads of
kind of recruiting or whatever so they
could talk to them but then JLo was like
I don't want to hang out I don't want to
be at somebody else's table I want to be
at your table and I came with you you're
my friend I don't know any of these
people and she's like all right so she
let her sit at her table and she was
like in trouble for that for that I was
a first mistake they made us grow floors
on every case
they did some [ __ ] like that to a road I
did like her vacation her her hiatus for
the next year on King of Queens
everybody else she was like everybody
wanted to make Bermuda and all the stuff
she said I went to Florida to clean
floors and take class with Adam Murray
they basically were punishing her let me
scare you
I love Scientology man it's crazy I love
in California of the history of it with
in California because that guy bought up
all these dilapidated properties it's
the primary would ya out in Hemet that's
the gold yeah one thing I'm really like
you have to give it up to the Church of
Scientology is how they beat up the IRS
all right and they saw most so they lost
their tax-exempt status for a while and
then they basically did some backroom
dealing with the IRS and got their
tax-exempt status back ten years ago I
remember watching that going clear thing
and it was like a big old thing I don't
know what the who the leader is but the
guy that's David Miscavige yeah the guy
that even turned on his parents right
yeah it was a bug to his parent he'd
beat his parents up when he was a
teenager he's crazy he thinks any short
like Tom Cruise - so they like they have
custom-made motorcycles and they go
riding their motorcycles together and
they work out together and it's all like
almost like Hitler s like you know
dictators styled speechmaking man he's
crazy crazy we do my first gig I land
right in Maryland the affort aberdeen
proving ground aberdeen proving ground
bro I show up bro with no luggage what
happened they lost it American put it on
a later flight you're lying
yeah man so I'm up to performing my
sweats there Corey Holcomb bring you a
head Blue's Clues
it's not easy either because the airport
is like an hour and a half away or an
hour away from this base so they bring
it all the way up an hour away abroad
and when I got back to my room when I
got back to my room
no no back brother not so I took a
shower put on the same clothes you know
that goes I always put my nose inside
out that there in the morning I get
through my bags there but did you what
was the show that night that I showed up
my back showed up yeah but I was afraid
he wasn't gonna get it because they
would have shown up after he was gone
the worst well what I didn't want to do
man it's true I have an hour to my next
show and then leave early to get to the
airport first to tear my bag is there
they came through oh they're my Blue's
Clues damn broke my sweats are you
comfortable onstage at least yeah cool
perform into my PJs man I made a man
into a workout room what's up fool
getting shots coming up bro what's up
okay I'm a podcast I got I got I got a
new will come out today's as a matter of
fact I think we're gonna do an enchilada
podcast to this week for some time on
Thanksgiving cuz you're home for a few
days in a row for a few days man I don't
know how I did it bro traveling or for
our four shows because I'm a get loose
sleep huh hell yeah dude
was it crazier than the than the that
Mike Epps tour so far the same yeah
sleepingwise yeah but now I manage how
to sleep for hours bro and get and get
enough rest
yeah we use you just basically cut sleep
everywhere you I stay for hours and up
and when I wake up from like I will get
up at 6 and they leave at 7 and that's
when I get in a plane fall asleep so
drive me somewhere it the drive me
somewhere that takes two hours I fall
asleep in a car everywhere bright fall
asleep I'll just tell again listen maybe
Co Taco Bell wake me up pull over
live it up Taco Bell yeah man what's up
fool he says out she's out of here now
she's gone alright
so you got heard of the shows of this
week we're Midland Texas you've been in
Midland Texas this comes out Friday
you're there Wednesday that's where the
bushes are from right you want me to put
the podcast out on Wednesday yeah okay
I'll get it out okay what's so fool
thing everybody I hope you guys had a
Happy Thanksgiving
we'll hear you guys see you guys next
week man